- What is that?
- Well, I have an
announcement to make everyone.
- Is that real?
- Signed scripts of Timeless
the Christmas Movie,
Part One and Part Two,
just for you from the cast.
(audience cheering)
- Oh my gosh,
you are so kind
and I kind of just hugged
your armpit, I'm sorry.
- Yeah no, it's okay.
- I didn't wanna lose them.
Oh my gosh, thank you.
- Oh my god thank you,
you single-handedly saved
our show twice I think.
- I did not,
but I do love that they
listened a little bit
because here's the thing,
it is such a great show,
I mean do you feel like
you could teach history at this point?
- Yes, so everyone gather around.
Not at all, I actually just
have a really good memory
and I was kind of "Beautiful
Mind"-ing all of those
historical tales from the show,
but I get stopped all
the time when I travel
from history professors
and teachers, like,
"Oh my gosh, I share
Timeless with my students",
and they'd think that I
know things and I'm like,
"You don't wanna ask me about that,
"but I could give you a
monologue about the cast".
(laughing)
- No, but I will say
that's one of the reasons
why I really love the show,
I thought it was so cool how it tied in
to historical events,
and how it just was kind of
a really innovative show,
nothing had been done like that.
- Thanks, it was like making
a different movie every week,
and you have a 12-year-old, right?
- Well he's 13 now, yes.
- My son is 11, and it was great to just
a show that I could do
that he could watch.
- Absolutely.